priorité santé déclare emmanuel macron à
l'issue du conseil de défense spéciales
cos vite de ce mardi une annonce qui se
traduit par de nouvelles mesures
fermeture des bars et restaurants du
département des bouches du rhône dès 23h
et masque obligatoire dans toute la
ville de marseille des restrictions qui
pourrait s'appliquer à paris un scénario
qu envisage désormais le porte parole du
gouvernement
rien est exclue par principe il ya un
travail qui engagez-vous constater aussi
que la circulation du virus est
importante dans la capitale et dans un
certain nombre de départements de la
petite couronne
d'ailleurs sur la région ile de france
il ya aussi une préoccupation est
évidemment le pré les préfets et les
élus sont en lien constant pour préparer
d'éventuelles nouvelles mesures
autre annonce attendue celle du ministre
de l'éducation nationale
à moins d'une semaine d'une inquiétante
rentrée pour plus de 12 millions
d'élèves
jean michel blanquer a précisé les
nouvelles règles à respecter dans les
établissements scolaires il est exact
qu'en juillet et août nous avions
envisagé quelques éventuels exception je
pense aux professeurs de maternelle je
pense à certaines situations
pédagogiques à une certaine distance
nous avons préféré ne pas maintenir ces
exceptions de façon à ce que la règle
soit totalement claire totalement simple
et puis qu'il n'y ait pas de casuistique
et donc j'ai vu que c'était aussi le
point de vue de une bonne partie des
organisations syndicales
une bonne partie des acteurs donc
aujourd'hui tout le monde doit retenir
cette idée très simple les adultes
portent le masque et les enfants les
élèves aussi s'agissant des élèves à
partir de la classe de 6e c'est le
principe socle de ce protocole sanitaire
le port du masque sera également rendue
obligatoire dans les entreprises à
partir de mardi prochain une mesure
qualifiée d' un peu brutale par le
patron du medef geoffroy roux de bézieux
lors de l'ouverture de l'université
d'été de l'organisation patronale
il appelle le gouvernement à l'essai de
la souplesse aux entreprises pour mettre
en place cette mesure également présents
à cette journée inaugurale
jean castex a levé le voile sur une
partie des dispositions du plan de
relance qui sera présentée le 3
septembre
parmi elles le maintien du chômage
partiel au moins jusqu'au 1er novembre
dans les entreprises qui sont encore
confrontés aujourd'hui à une réduction
d'activité durable me conduit également
à vous annoncer que l'activité partielle
demeurera ouverte dans ces conditions
actuelles au moins jusqu'au 1er novembre
au moins jusqu'au 1er novembre et au
delà pendant deux ans pour toutes les
entreprises couvertes par un accord sur
l'activité partielle longue durée demain
matin le locataire de matignon tiendra
une conférence de presse aux côtés des
ministres de la santé olivier véran et
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
il devrait faire le point sur l'épidémie
département par département
défendez nouvelles mesures et appelé à
davantage de vigilance